c'est le genre de formation couru par
les Taïwanais la préparation à une
tentative d'invasion chinoise
cette nouvelle portion du cours ajoutée
récemment porte sur la désinformation
de journalistes citoyens formés à
utiliser tous les outils disponibles
pour vérifier les faits
la désinformation et les cyber-attaques
sont courantes partout dans le monde
mais pire à Taïwan qui a enregistré près
de 6 millions de cyberattaques chinoises
par jour l'an dernier la visite de la
présidente de la Chambre des
représentants américains Nancy Pelosi a
servi de prétexte pour intensifier la
pression le nombre de cyber-attaques a
été multiplié par 23
et a sorti de campagne de désinformation
sans précédent d'où l'importance des
formations pour contrer cette
manipulation des utilisateurs
l'autre grande priorité est d'assurer
une connexion à toute épreuve à la toile
et au monde extérieur en cas d'attaque
chinoise le réseau taïwanais dépend
d'Internet par fibre optique provenant
du continent des câbles qui pourraient
être sectionnés
inspiré par la résilience ukrainienne
Taïwan sauvegarde toutes ces données et
construit son propre réseau d'appoint
internet par satellite mais pas par un
fournisseur unique Taïwan semi-fi de
Starlink Delon musk prenant récemment
les idées de la Chine totalitaire
dans cette formation pour contrer la
désinformation chinoise on espère
surtout que c'est le seul genre
d'attaque que la Chine lancera contre
Taïwan ici Philippe Leblanc radio